they're set coordinates 1 1 5 2 2 6 1 0
gonna straight up Waterloo pattern how'd
you end up here you wash out a flight
school I didn't wash out must be a lot
of pressure in a four-star generals
daughter we should really get back to
work if you don't want to talk about it
I understand some of mine have this
could be the break I've been waiting for
an entire month
the colonel tells you who to take out
then you do it don't think too much
don't worry
yep okay and you're positive visual idea
the target yeah it's him please inform
command immediately currently at the
location
um there's several unidentified
terrorist suspects this is chapter
there's civilians and kids just way it's
gone around here man
leave her 13 what have you got I will
not kill 12 civilians hold for general
Lawson hello Susan
dad you're about to ruin your whole life
you swore an oath to defend the United
States from her enemies now honor that
oath you have a top-level al-qaida
operative in your sights and I expect
him to be in the devil's hands within
three minutes this was wrong thing it's
insane dad contract and I wouldn't have
had to drop bombs and thousands of
non-combatants
this technology is going to win us the
war
you
[Music]